Okay!
Hey, everybody!
Oh, hey!
Hey!
Oh, my God, guys!
Are you looking forward to watching me play Marvel Rivals today?
Woo!
We're not doing that, unfortunately.
Aww!
You were this close to... You were very, very close to playing Tetris 99 with the audience, so... Oh, my God!
Wait!
Can we do that?
Reschedule now!
Change everything!
I want to play Tetris 99!
Yeah, let's just do that.
That's what... Now, so here, for those of you who don't know how our show works, we're going to be people from the audience.
So, we need people who are just have lots of energy and are here to have fun and want to do all the wonderful fun things.
So, I need four contestants for this next segment.
Let's see some heads.
Who wants to be a contestant for this next segment?
Alright, wow, we have a lot of people who are willing to be contestants.
Whoa!
You guys don't even know what the game is!
Yeah!
But does it matter what the game is?
So, you know what the game is.
Should I tell the audience what the game is, or should I just pick people without them just completely understanding?
No, let them, like, if it's a bad game, then they have to deal with it.
Yeah.
That's alright.
Well, you've heard our guest, so let's go ahead and pick four people from the audience.
Um, Griffith and Bryce, do you have any preferences on what you want to help pick, or do you want me to pick?
I can't see that.
Okay, there's a guy that's standing up, like...
Alright, alright, we'll go with the blue light stick.
Oh, the blue light, yeah.
Yeah, go ahead and go over to the stage, uh, to stage left.
Oh, this, okay, yeah.
Yeah, I was gonna say, this guy stood up.
This guy stood up.
Alright, I'm gonna, wow, you gotta, you have a lot of people with sticks at this show.
This is great.
Woo!
Alright, I'm gonna go ahead and we're gonna pick, we're gonna go over here with the, with the two light sticks over here.
Come on up.
Yeah, come on up, go to the stage left.
And...
So what I want you to do, well, so let me explain to you what you're gonna do.
I want you to know where I'm.
Two pairs of two people, please.
Two pairs of two people.
Okay, great.
Well, you're with a VTuber professional and performer.
You're gonna dance.
That's right!
We've chosen a selection of copyright-free tracks that you can absolutely dance to.
Our handlers will take you to the side.
You need to make a 60-second dance.
And you have about five minutes to prepare.
So, good luck, guys!
Okay, bye!
Yeah, yeah, you'll be in the next scene.
You're gonna go off stage.
You're gonna dance.
And guess who's gonna judge?
This person up here.
Yeah, I'm gonna watch you dance.
Alright.
That's why I hear what the thing is before you raise your head.
You should always check sometimes what you're getting into, so...
But that's okay.
So, where is the next game?
We're gonna do...
Yeah, we're gonna do this right here.
Okay.
Can I also have...
So, while during that... I don't have any downtime.
I'm gonna go straight into our second game.
I need four more people, and...
I want something who... people who are artistic.
Artistic.
People look lower their heads, they're like, Oh, wait, that's not me.
Okay, hold on.
Can we...
Uh, hold on.
Oh, yeah, they're doing name tags.
Okay, that's great.
Alright, let's go get four artistic people.
You guys are gonna go ahead, downstage, so that you can be seen.
Alright, let's see.
We need four artistic people.
Uh...
Yeah, any artistic people?
Yeah, okay.
With the...
I know you guys are talented.
With the Pokeball?
Oh, okay.
Now, we have a rule.
If you volunteer your friends, you volunteer yourself.
So...
Alright, go ahead.
Yes, yes.
Go ahead and take a seat over here at those.
Give us a seat.
Yeah, people coming on.
Uh...
I'm gonna go over on this side.
And I'm going to go ahead and...
Yes!
Yay!
Come on up.
You know, into this area.
Yeah.
Uh, yes.
Our friend with the...
Sit up here.
Yeah, yeah.
They're doing the dancing game.
You're doing...
Yeah, don't worry.
You guys are safe.
You don't have to embarrass yourself.
Yeah.
They're strong.
And we have...
We have one more務.
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Come on up.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, come on down.
Yee!
Yee- Mom!
Yee-isms!
Alright, so what is this game?
Well, we got an Intruder Circuit.
Oh...
Plus, look at the Kness repository and I'll tell them where the game is.
So...
Yeah.
Okay, so I need to stall for a little bit of tim.
Alright.
We're giving you names.
I don't have a mic, but you don't have a mic, but I have a mic.
So what's your name?
Nikkel?
Where are you from?
You're from Nevada.
I love Nevada.
Where's that?
Are you from the good part of Nevada or the evil part of Nevada?
The good part of Nevada.
That's a good answer.
And what's your name?
Kimmy, where are you from?
You're from here?
Are you from the good California or the evil California?
Monterrey.
Yeah, they're good.
Monterrey, California.
That trick answer is all evil.
Well, if you're going to be like that... And our third contestant.
Shani.
And where are you from?
You're from here too.
Okay.
Have...
No, no, I was going to ask you.
But you see how this is a bad thing.
He's like, oh, yay.
And our contestant number four, what's your name?
May.
And where are you from?
You're also from Nevada.
Have you met?
Whoa.
Do you want to?
Just say hi.
There you go.
Now you've met.
Those are the contestants.
So there's our four contestants.
We are going to need the markers and the...
We are going to do the drawing round.
That's why we need the artist... That's why we need people who are artistic here.
So what I'm going to do is I'm going to give each of you some prompts.
One prompt at a time.
And our guest is going to judge both.
She's going to give you points if she can tell what it is.
And she's going to judge who's better.
So draw real good.
Yeah.
Yep.
Yeah, we're going to give you proper paper.
We're going to give you proper markers that stay in your hands that will never come off.
So that's okay.
Okay.
So your prompt is...
Wait, I'm going to know what the prompt is?
No, no.
Your job is to guess the prompt.
If you figure it out...
If they draw something and you totally whiff, that's hilarious.
So that's kind of...
Don't worry.
I can cheat.
Okay.
Anyway, here's your prompt.
Your prompt number one.
Okay.
Is it a dog?
That's prompt number nine.
Okay, your prompt number one.
Okay.
And your prompt number two.
Dog, cat, house, tomato.
Two.
Your prompt number two.
Tomato.
Spaghetti.
You're going to have to learn real fast.
And prompt number two.
Okay.
Alright.
That face!
She made a face!
That's a bad prompt!
Alright.
I'll put it this way.
That's a bad prompt.
You have 60 seconds.
You can try to look for a reference image.
Your time starts now.
Don't worry.
I'll screenshot the picture so everyone can see it.
Yeah.
Oh, that's fantastic.
That'd be great.
Look at the draw.
Yeah.
So how are you?
How is Canada for you?
I mean, it's pretty alright.
I'm inside.
Like, I'm not touching grass or anything.
Oh, but the outside is where all the fun is.
Like, all the bugs and all the wind and all the dust.
The more you go outside, the higher chance you'll die.
You know?
Anything can happen outside.
I'm in a controlled environment right now.
Well, that's absolutely very, very safe.
So, I appreciate you being on the inside, as they say.
Exactly.
Well, I'm going to give them another 20 seconds.
I look at their drawings.
And let me go through a preview of their drawings.
And...
Those are good!
Oh!
She slammed her!
Oh, yeah.
We have a dominant player here.
She's done done.
She's so confident.
So...
Whatever, you're going to have to figure out what is...
What is good.
So...
I'm curious on the person who didn't know what to do.
She was...
I saw, she was like, I don't know what that is.
We're going to find out together.
And in five, four, three, two, one...
Hands down.
Caps on.
Because we don't...
Yeah.
See, that's what happens when you slam the cap.
Alright.
Let's see.
Can I have cadences one and three?
Alright.
Don't worry, guys.
Oh, okay.
Wait.
Alright.
No, that's easy as hell.
Let me save this real quick so everyone else can see.
They must be like, what the fuck are we looking at right now?
Oh, we're freaking out.
Alright.
This is what we're looking at.
I mean...
It's clearly butter toast, right?
It is exactly correct.
Now, which of our contestants did the better job?
Oh, man.
Oh, that's difficult.
I mean...
You can say...
The one to the far right, there's two butter toasts.
And two is butter toasts.
That's good.
It's boring to eat, you know?
Alright, well, bonus points to our contestants on our right.
And it's a hot butter toast, too, because you can see the lies.
I don't want cold butter toasts.
Ah, the best kind.
Alright.
And contestants number two and four, can you show me what...
Yeah, show our audience what you have here.
Now, this is...
What the fuck is that?
Like, I just want to shoot it.
You guys, not you.
But...
She said it.
Yeah, yeah.
Like, I don't even think it's like...
I don't think it has rights.
Like...
What is that?
I'm sorry, I didn't make it bigger.
I can't tell.
Is this League of Legends?
Alright.
Does anyone in the audience have a guess on this?
Yes.
Is it Sylveon?
It is Sylveon!
Oh my god!
Thank you!
Like, okay, okay.
I'm...
I'm so like...
Why does she have one ribbon?
And what does she have...
Oh...
Okay, guys.
Okay, okay.
Let me...
Alright, guys.
I'm Googling Sylveon.
Okay, please.
Please do.
Alright.
I am...
I'm...
I'm sad.
Oh, yes, yes, yeah.
We have a comment over here.
Yes.
I don't know what Sylveon is.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
She was the one who said she had no idea what Sylveon was.
Does not know Pockabon.
I'm gonna...
You don't know what Syl...
Oh, I'm so...
Oh my gosh.
Don't be nice to her, Texas.
Don't rage bait me.
Nice.
No, no, no, no, no.
She's rage baiting.
There's no way.
Oh.
Yeah.
Okay.
Okay, so who did the better job between these two?
They don't even have bows!
You have to pick a winner.
I don't even want to pick a winner.
The other girl that drew the other Butter Toast, you won.
Contestants, can you flip your sheets over?
You're gonna get another prompt.
Now, you're gonna get two prompts.
You're gonna have to somehow do your best to combine them.
That's all I can say, okay?
You're gonna get prompts...
All four of you are gonna do this.
You're gonna get to do prompts 9 and 10.
9 and 10, okay?
9 and 10?
Yeah.
Oh, no, no, don't cheat, don't cheat.
You have a camera here, can't you?
9 and 10, okay?
And 9 and 10.
Yeah.
You can add whatever details or flourishes.
All you have to do is just get both...
If she gets both parts of this, you know, however you do it, that's fine.
We're gonna give them 75 seconds.
A minute and 15.
Your time starts now.
Now, now.
Now, the Sumion thing.
Now.
While they're drawing.
Now, now.
It wasn't that bad.
I mean...
I...
We're not here to coddle people, okay?
Now, now.
Now, we didn't...
We...
I couldn't get the scene set up in time.
But you were...
There was a...
In the original design, you were gonna draw for the audience at some point.
They were gonna judge you.
Okay, I can draw Sylvie on.
I...
I can...
Do it!
Can you do it in the next 35 seconds?
I can...
Okay, I will draw Sylvie on right now.
Okay.
Woo!
All right.
Well, the challenge has been thrown, so...
Uh...
Well, for all of you out there, if you could draw Sylvie on, why not draw one on your phone?
Just have fun with that.
And then, like...
Like...
I'm just...
It looks...
Already looks like Sylvie on!
Like...
Oh...
We can't see what you're drawing yet.
Okay, no, I...
There...
I literally just drew this in, like, 10 seconds.
Seconds.
And then you can look at this and be like, yeah, that's Sylvie on.
All right.
Like, I have all the important details in there.
All right, here.
Okay, so...
This is your Sylvie on.
Okay, this is MY Sylvie on.
All right, the point has been noted.
I will...
All right, I think that's enough.
I'm gonna give you five more seconds.
Five...
Four...
Three...
Two...
One...
Cancel down, caps on.
This is gonna be the last one.
We need to show...
So remember, this is two prompts combined.
So you would have to give me both parts.
They might have added other flourishes.
They were encouraging you.
So let's show our camera operators your pictures, please.
All right, redeem yourself.
Okay, I was like...
Dude, at first, I...
Okay, for one of them, I was like, am I dead?
Like, it looked like...
It looked like cooking Mufasa and Simba.
This is some reason.
I think you could tell which one I thought was...
Mufasa and Simba.
And I was like...
Oh my god, am I like...
Crying at my...
At Mufasa's body?
Like...
All right, that's what I mean.
And you guys can tell which one I thought was Mufasa and Simba.
Like...
This one right here.
Oh, someone's gonna be out of the wall.
Wait, let me...
Okay, Mufasa and Simba.
It's like, all right, all that I'm saying...
Okay, I'm gonna show a picture to you, and then like...
And then you guys would think it's definitely the same thing.
Like...
Oh, I'm not.
Like, right here.
That's...
That...
Yeah, that's it.
That's actually...
I'm like, Dad, no!
All right, so...
Okay, all right, anyway, back to...
No, no, no, this is fine.
Judging this contest.
So...
What...
What two...
What two prompts were used to create these four wonderful masterpieces?
Like...
I don't understand the stinky part.
Am I...
Like, am I actually dead?
Right?
Um...
It has to do something with me and Dad.
So...
I don't know.
I'm...
Like, he's sleeping, I assume.
He's sleeping, and he wants...
To my attention.
I'm just gonna say, the second contestant, the Mufasa contestant, is actually the closest to what I have on the card.
Oh, so was it actually Mufasa?
No, no, no, no, it was...
Um...
I'll give you all points, because I think you recognize that it's all...
It is all Dad.
Yeah!
And the second one is...
The second prompt was Body Pillow.
Oh!
Body Pillow!
So that is you...
I still think this is a better prompt.
So, I'm gonna say, is that...
That is...
That is Doki curled up on a Dad Body Pillow.
Is that what that is?
Oh!
That is a nice...
That is actually genuinely very sweet.
I like that.
Mufasa's still dead.
Alright.
So, since they all...
You identified that.
Who...
Which of our four contestants did the best?
Which of them?
Yes.
Well, I didn't get the...
I didn't get the Body Pillow correct.
No, you didn't get that.
So, but you still...
You can still judge...
You can still judge on artistic merit, and uh...
Oh, that's the wrong picture.
Let me look at all of them.
Yeah.
Let me look at all of them real quick.
Alright.
Oops, sorry.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, so why am I...
Why is he stinky?
Wait, I just...
Yeah, why...
Why...
Why stinky?
Oh!
The...
The Body Pillow says, Ya, Oni-chan, and Baka.
Oh my gosh!
Okay.
So, who do you think gets the points for this round?
Okay, I think, honestly, I will have to...
I'm sorry, but the Mufasa one caught my attention the most.
Well, give it up for...
What's your name again?
Jenny!
Jenny are winner!
Alright.
Uh, did we have the little trinkets, the little small balls that we have?
The little big...
There's a big box of Spy Family, uh, little trinkets.
Or give them some medals, too.
Whoa!
We have a lot of medals we can give them, too.
We have medals?
Oh my gosh!
Yeah, we're gonna give you all medals, so...
Mad one?
Huh?
Mad one, too?
Oh yeah, absolutely!
Nice!
We have...
We have ones that say winner, and then we have a bunch that say...
Yeah, that's me.
We have a bunch that says, you tried.
So...
Now, I have the winner one.
Okay.
Now, we are going to do one more game at the end.
You're a winner.
Can you come back in about 20 minutes for this?
Yeah, okay, good.
Stay... stick around, we'll call you back, Jenny.
So, uh, as soon as the medals come out, can you please give it up for our four contestants who had no idea what was going on!
Yay!
All right, go ahead and collect your prizes from stage left.
Or actually, if you don't, you guys can just dole them out.
Just dole them out the prizes, yeah.
All right.
Thank you for joining us.
Go ahead and make your way out.
Take your drawings with you.
You can get them framed.
Yeah!
They're good!
You should be proud of yourselves.
I love them!
I'm so joking!
Let's go!
Now, who here remembers from a few minutes ago that we had a dance act?
We had two dance acts lined up.
Me too!
All right, can we have our first dance act come over here to kind of this performing area where it's a little bit of open-ended in the light of sight?
Come on up.
Do you feel confident in yourself right now?
Yeah, you have no idea.
Now, you have... over here.
Yeah, stand over here.
All right.
What do we have?
We have names and your name is?
Cafe Clone.
Yep.
And you are?
Eric, what song did you pick?
Sugar.
Sugar!
Sugar from the YouTube Audio Library.
Wow!
Bring up the pool!
Look, we just told you to choreograph.
You have one minute.
I'm going to go ahead and play you in on my side.
Hopefully that will work.
Yay!
Cringe Keno!
Let's go!
Yeah.
It's going to be great.
This is a great idea and we have no regrets about doing this show.
All right, here we go.
This is Sugar.
Guys don't...
Oh, come on guys.
All right, here we go.
In three, two, one, go.
Oh, sorry.
Oh, oh, oh!
Yes, you're right back!
Turn around!
Oh my gosh!
It's amazing!
There we go.
Oh my gosh!
Yeah!
Take it!
Woo-hoo!
That's my copyright to music.
That's great.
That is for your minimum wage job at the top of the job.
Let's go!
Three, two, one!
Let's bring on our second team.
They were so excited, they had no idea what was going on.
Have a seat in our chairs, on the stage here.
Now, you two, go over there and go over here on the performance to art.
And you two, sit here.
All right.
What song?
Oh, let's get her.
I'm all out of order.
That's my fault.
What's your name?
Mako.
Yes.
You are?
Abraxas.
I love these cosplays.
Now, what song did you choose?
Window Shopping.
Window Shopping?
Yeah, we didn't want to get copyright claims, so...
Thanks.
You know, it's part of what we have to do here, unfortunately.
It's okay, your song is Window Shopping.
You guys... That's right, I'll copyright claim this.
All right, let's go!
Oh my god, they're acting!
Oh my god, they're really rock!
That's what it is!
They're using, oh my god!
You can actually do these props!
I'm right there.
Oh my god, that
was...
All right, let's have a wedding now!
Woo!
They fell in love and got married!
I will say, when we wrote this, we did not expect to see a marriage!
Now, I will say that this is the third marriage...
Just like Las Vegas!
I think this is the third marriage we've had at the convention in the last ten years, so they're legally binding now.
Wow, congratulations!
It's legally binding, apparently!
Well, for those of you who don't...
There was one couple, ten years ago, they met in speed dating, and then they got married on stage at stage zero.
Oh my god, it's like pre-discord!
Yeah!
All right, so we have Cafe and... your name?
Eric.
And versus Abraxas and Mako, who here did the better job, in your opinion, in your professional opinion?
I would have to say, it's been done for a couple of shoes, because one gave me a story and a marriage.
But then, like, the first one, they were very enthusiastic.
When I said, turn around and smack that, the guy turned around and started shaking.
And I was like, you know what?
That guy clearly wanted to dance for the money.
So I had to go with number one.
All right.
Congratulations, Kelly!
Thank God!
All right, can we get some mini prizes for our runners-up, Abraxas and Mako?
And our two winners, two winners, and Ginny.
Again, we're going to call you back in about ten minutes.
Can I get another medal?
Oh yeah, we're going to have more medals, yeah!
Yay!
I love these medals.
I want more medals.
Yeah, I want more.
I want to buy a bunch of medals that say 5th place and just give them to everybody.
Okay, then it's not as special anymore.
Well, these are branded, so we can't use these after you.
So we have to give them away now.
All right, we're going to do another trivia-type game and I think...
Whoa!
Yeah, we're going to do a basic one.
We have about ten minutes before the final, I think.
Yeah, we can do that.
Yippee!
All right, and you're going to play too.
Well, I mean, I hope I get to play.
This is my panel.
Well, you've been judging.
You've been working very hard.
I want to play too.
All right, well then you get to play.
Thank you very much.
If you guys go ahead and take back your seats.
I love this window-shopping music.
It's like I'm in an elevator right now.
Oh, I have to mute this out of the Discord.
I'm sorry about that.
You've been listening to this in the last three minutes, so...
Yeah, I have to say it, but I think only was listening to this.
Yes, yes, you're out of the house.
Yeah, I was listening to window-shopping the last, like, I don't know, five minutes or so.
Oh, the next time we do this, we're going to have, we're going to use copyrighted music, but only the contestants can hear.
They just have to, they have headphones, so only they can hear.
I see.
I think that'll be fun.
Oh, we'll do that next time.
I can copyright claim because you're using my image.
Ooh.
Scary, she's starting to scare me.
She's right behind me, isn't it?
Alright, I need four more contestants for this segment.
Whoa, yeah, people are so excited.
Yeah, a lot of people go ahead.
You don't even know what it is.
Yeah.
Well, it is a little bit of trivia.
You need to know stuff.
You need to know video games.
Oh, video game knowledge time.
Yeah, that's fair.
My dragons better be gamers.
Alright, go ahead with the purple.
That's all we do.
The, uh, go ahead in the, oh, with the, oh, with the tie.
You, sir.
Yes, with the tie, yes.
You, sir, you look smart.
You have a tie on.
Ties are good.
Alright, but is this a clip-on or an actual tie?
It's an actual tie.
Oh, it's real.
He knows, okay, but did your mom tie your tie or did you tie your tie?
I knew it.
Can't fool me.
Alright, let's go to the, let's go to the back here with the, uh, Oh, with the, in the yellow over here.
And I need, go ahead and have a seat.
Wait, I need a kid with glasses.
Yeah, go ahead.
No, sit, sit down.
That's when I know they're smart.
Sit down on the chair.
Yeah, go ahead.
And, oh, we need, we need more fun contestants.
Who here has energy?
Yeah, a guy with glasses.
Or a girl with glasses.
Yeah, go ahead and you, and...
Yeah.
Oh, you want, you want glasses?
Yeah, I want glasses.
Alright.
Uh, uh, uh, uh, yeah, let's, let's, oh, I'm trying to, I'm trying to find, oh man, man, there are so many things.
Yeah, he's like, look at me, I'm holding glasses right now.
I, I, what?
You.
Yes, you.
Does he have glasses on?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
The one...
I love it.
Oh my god.
I love giving you this.
I got contacts on, too.
That's okay, uh, over here in this other chair.
Oh my god, he pretended to wear glasses!
That's dumb.
That's the word he's in real.
All right, hold on.
No, no, no, no.
We can fix this.
Here's your name tag.
Where are your glasses right now?
Your name tag is L-I-A-R.
There you go.
That's right.
Never that shame.
V-R, yes.
That's right.
Oh, what happened to my show?
Don't worry.
I'll immoralize you.
All right.
We're going to need someone... Oh, no, I can help you score.
Okay.
Let's introduce our contestants.
We have about eight minutes in this segment.
And I'm going to use this one.
Something happened.
What's going on?
Oh, God.
Oh, no.
What is your name?
Hi, Chase.
Oh, you have glasses anymore.
Oh, you have glasses now.
Okay.
Not a liar.
Chase, and we have...
Danny, and we have...
Rocket Launcher, and we have...
Simon, thank you very much.
And we have on here, Doki.
Doki's going to play too.
Not a liar.
All right.
We are going to do a simple game of...
Guess the game from the screenshot.
The earlier you get it, you get more points.
We're going to go in order.
And if you make a mistake...
Oh, sorry.
If you give me the wrong answer, it goes on to the next person.
So there's lots of...
Oh, so it's like Jeopardy rules.
Yeah.
Exactly like Jeopardy rules, except for the parts that are not.
So...
Okay.
All right.
So...
So the questions will get low-res and blurry, and they will get sharper.
All you have to do is just say what the next...
Ask for the next one.
So we're going to go in order.
Simon, you're on my...
You're on my left, or at least the audience left.
Oh my god, it's like GameDoll.
Yeah, that's actually closer to what it is.
So here we go.
Let's look at the first picture.
For 100 points.
100 points?
We're not going to start with one?
Nah, we're going to do 100.
Can you name what this is?
Simon?
5 Moribals.
Well, Jokey...
All right, let's go figure this out here.
Um, 2, 3, 4, and 5.
I can't afford to have a rival, guys.
That was instant.
I recognize that one area.
All right.
We're not going to get that.
That one map.
You said I could play!
It's not on the fist, I'm your turn!
It doesn't matter.
I'm Betty.
Okay.
Fine.
We're going to do it this way.
You're going to have to shut up.
Go ahead.
What do you think?
Everyone versus me.
What I'm saying...
Okay, okay.
You choose...
Okay, when it's their turn, you have to figure it out before I figure it out.
Yeah, it's going to be a race.
Okay?
Yeah, yeah, it's a race.
So when it's your turn, you have to make sure you figure it out before I do.
Yeah.
So if she gets it on the first one, more power to you.
You know, good luck.
All right.
So that was Marvel Rivals.
Here is number two.
That was like one second.
That was pretty crazy.
Here we go.
Good luck.
What the fuck is that?
Let's just see how it's sad.
Five, two, one.
Oh, Simpsons hit and run.
What do you think about this?
Is that Simpsons game?
Simpsons game is different.
It is hit and run.
It is correct.
It lacks everything.
He's fine.
The plow king.
And of course...
It's way easier when you have the boss to work with to find images for the face.
It's like, now we're going to test if you're an actual screen watching.
That's pretty much...
All right.
Let's try number three again.
Shout it, shout it.
Don't worry about raising your hand.
Just shout it out.
Yeah.
Because she's shouting.
She's not raising her hand.
Did you just raise it?
Yeah, I'm not.
I'm not polite.
No.
Here we go.
I want to win.
The next question is...
I'm here to win, guys.
Here we go.
Stardew Valley.
It is not Stardew Valley.
Oh, I know what it is.
So I feel bad.
So I'm going to make sure you...
Let's see how far you can get.
All right.
Two.
I know what it is.
Shout it out if you think you know.
Yeah, it's Pokemon.
It's Pokemon.
Not Pokemon.
We're on my stream right now.
Mario Kart!
I can't.
Huh?
Yeah, you got it in first.
I think I'm going to go give it to all three of you.
You got...
I can't...
You're wearing a thing on your head, so I can't tell if you're saying the answer.
You're wearing a box on your head.
This might be a problem.
He's like, yeah, and I'm not taking it off.
Let's figure out the rest of this.
Yay!
And there we go.
It's Mario Kart!
Oh, Nick.
Where did you get a mustache?
I'm Mario.
I'm Tokyo.
I'm Italian.
Every Italian has a mustache.
Okay.
Let's do...
Let's do two...
Oh, this has a note on it.
You come out of the womb with a mustache.
Let's do a couple more.
We need a winner here, so here we go.
Yeah, I gave a pity win.
Two.
Huh?
Three.
Oh, but now I'm confused.
Oh my god, that's a sponsor.
It's one of my sponsors.
Four.
Let's go.
Okay, yeah, you got to be more specific, because a lot of the gacha games, they sort of blur together.
Yeah, but I think I have to give that one, as soon as she recognizes where it's from, that's...
All right, this one, we're going to try to break a tie.
We want to see, we want a clear winner here, so let's try the next picture.
I mean, the clear winner is obviously me.
Well, I know the clear winner.
We thought for a chance, we thought for a chance that the cadences might win, but no, we realize this is wrong, so...
All right, of course.
I wanted more.
All right, let's see.
Can you get it off of this?
Can I get it off of this?
Apex?
Correct!
Actually, you got it.
Actually, that's correct.
Wait, is that Apex?
Yeah!
That's...
Apex!
Yeah!
Uh, well, there you go, and...
That's not fair!
Who is that macro?
Is that New District?
I don't play New District.
I don't know that!
Well done for getting it on the piece of wood.
That's actually amazing.
If it was any other map that's not New District, I would have got it.
Let's go to one more.
And have fun on this one.
Two.
Overwatch!
Two!
That's Tracer's Gun, I recognize it.
Overwatch 2?
There's no way that's not Overwatch!
I was gonna say, there's no way I recognize Tracer's Gun.
I specifically was waiting for someone to say Overwatch 2.
That's basically Overwatch.
It's basically...
That's Overwatch DLC.
Alright.
I have to wrap this up, so let's go really, really fast on this next one.
One.
Two.
Oh, Fortnite!
Yeah, it is Fortnite!
That's Fortnite!
Fortnite!
There you go!
And you can play with Darth Vader!
Alright.
Well, I think we have a winner, our liar here, Clyde.
That's Chase.
Chase.
Oh, that guy!
Congratulations, Chase!
You've won!
Thank you very much!
You have some more to me, send your show.
And give us a raise to serve your result.
I hope you have fun.
There we go.
Just how it goes.
You knew what you were getting to when you showed up here today, is what we're saying.
Alright.
Thank you very much.
We're gonna give medals and...
We're going to give medals and runner-up presents for all of you.
And we're gonna call Chase and Jenny and our dancers up onto audience left in just a little moment.
Give us a moment to reset and we'll be right with you.
Woah!
What the fuck?
Sonic the Hedgehog?
Sonic, what are you doing here?
What are you doing here?
You know you're in Big Mouth now?
You're in the newest season of Big Mouth.
Yes.
Okay, let's get...
Oh no.
Thank you very much.
You guys can go ahead and return your seats.
Chase, you can stay.
Jenny, you can go ahead and grab a slot.
And where are our dancers?
Stay.
Stay, stay.
Yeah, yeah.
Cafe and...
Yep, go ahead and take seats as we all switch in and out.
Oh wait, is this the last game?
This is gonna be the last game.
We're gonna pick one of these people are gonna win, and then you're gonna play a bonus round with them.
Oh, okay.
You're in the bonus round.
I'm the bonus round?
Okay.
Yeah.
You're...
You're on the contestant's...
Well, you should have been on the...
Wait, I wanna play the real round too.
Yes.
Oh, you are gonna play the real round.
You'll see what's gonna happen like.
It's gonna be...
Alright, cool.
Good luck.
It's hard.
But that's okay.
Don't worry, I have Google.
Alright, let's switch...
Now...
Now who's the nerd?
No.
Alright, let's go ahead and do this.
So here's how we do it.
We need one of you to come...
One of you to be the winner.
So we're gonna just do a very, very simple game.
We're just gonna...
I'm gonna give you a category.
I have 17 correct answers in this category.
You just need to give me one of them.
And we'll keep going.
Seventeen?
Yeah.
And you just have to keep going until...
If you mess up, then you're out and the last person standing is the winner.
Okay?
Who should go first?
Just out of curiosity.
No, Gabe, did you have a preference?
Just left to right.
Okay, left to right.
There we go.
Yep, my screen's catching up.
Discord is like that sometimes.
Anyway, your final category is...
Playable characters in Street Fighter 2.
Ohhhh.
Huh?
Old school.
Playable characters in Street Fighter 2.
Wow.
Doki.
Alright, so we're gonna start with here with Chase.
Give me one of them.
Uh, Cammy.
Cammy is correct.
And Ginny, we have...
Chun-Li.
Go ahead.
Uncle...
Guile.
Guile, correct.
Ken.
Honda.
Ryu.
Blanca.
Correct.
And Bison.
We're getting smart.
We have Smart Contestants Day.
Bro, we have Street Fighter players here.
What the fuck?
Jury.
No, that was a three.
It was four.
Sorry, not four.
Sorry, thank you very much.
Goodbye, nerd!
Thank you very much.
Uh, Jenny?
Wait, wait, wait.
Don't do it yet.
Oh no, we got more medals.
Oh, thank you.
Just more medals, there you go.
You tried.
I don't want to time you out, but I have to.
Time?
Oh, that's when you know it's serious.
Zangief is correct.
Oh!
Akuma is correct.
I can't believe you guys picked Zangief so late.
That is not correct.
Well played though.
Alright, thank you.
Goodbye.
Alright, now we're down to two nervous contestants.
A lot.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven.
Yes, there were 17 of them.
I don't know where there's 17 in Street Fighter 2.
She's got the advantage.
Come on a friend.
Three seconds.
Oh.
Two.
Whoa.
Oh, that's time.
Can you give me one?
You're going to go, who?
Dan Hibiki.
Oh no, it's not Dan Hibiki.
Oh, we have a tie.
Yeah, I'm going to get...
So now it's just whoever gives me any correct answer.
Any correct answer.
She's locked in.
Yeah.
You can tell.
They're both thinking.
She's...
Oh my God, I need to change on that.
These are the characters that people...
These are the characters that people hate.
So don't worry.
It's okay.
What is it?
This Richard guy, his name is?
You said it.
So you can say it loud.
Judges?
It's like...
I'm kidding.
You said...
You said Dalsim.
You want to give it to him on a schwa?
No.
I'll count it.
All right.
It's Dalsim.
Dalsim.
On a schwa.
Well done.
Thank you very much.
And you get a medal.
All right.
You were so locked in.
You almost got out.
You were locked in.
Wow.
Nervous contestants.
Okay.
We are now going to go on to our final challenge.
Where is our...
Wait, where did you go?
Yeah.
Hang on here.
Can I have a game, my game board operator?
Would you like to...
Oh, wait.
It's bonus round.
It's my turn.
Yes, it is.
Don't worry.
Google.
Yes, there you go.
All right.
Do you have your own sheeted questions?
You should if you don't.
It's...
Here you go.
There you go.
All right.
We're going to go ahead and stand over here.
Do either of these mics on stage work?
Let me get this out.
Let's see...
No, no.
It's...
One, two, one, two.
I want to be able to hear our contestant.
There we go.
Here.
Okay.
All right.
Cool.
And now, for this round, you don't have to do anything.
What?
Oh.
Yeah.
You need us to stand here and pay attention.
Doki, hi.
Just stand here and look for you.
All right.
Hello.
I'm going to go over on this side of the stage.
Actually, I'm going to go on this side of the stage.
I'm going to try to get in the frame.
Is that okay?
All right.
So what do I have to do?
Well, I have 21 questions.
Wait, I have to answer all 21?
If you clear 21 questions in three minutes, this gentleman here will win $100.
If I don't get it?
No, no.
If you do get it...
He doesn't win $100.
If you don't get it, he does not win.
Okay, I forfeit.
Alright, it should be like I get the $100.
Like why does this...
You know what?
Let me make a call.
Hello?
Yeah.
Okay, fine.
If you get it in 3 minutes, you will also get $100.
Okay, I like that.
Okay.
Now, these questions are not meant to be that hard.
We've seen some other shows before.
So they're questions like...
They're all either or questions.
Okay.
Mario or Luigi, which one wears red?
Oh, okay.
Yeah, they're stupid easy.
And I'm stupid.
London or Paris, what's the capital, France.
And your job is to get every question wrong.
Wait, what?
You need to get every question wrong.
Okay, and then that would be red.
Yes.
Mario or Luigi, which one wears red?
You say...
Luigi.
There you go.
And London or Paris, what's the capital of France?
You say...
London.
Now, she's playing, but you're...
She's playing, but she's playing on behalf of you.
Yes?
Okay, so, yeah.
So, shh.
No help from the audience.
She needs to be locked in.
I need to be locked in now.
I need to be just like her.
Okay, so are you ready to...
Oh, so, if you give me the correct answer, we will go back to the beginning.
If you take too long, we will also go back to the beginning.
Okay.
So, and when we...
They will be the same questions, so I might go a little bit faster at the same time.
You can always talk.
You can always interrupt me, but I think you know that already.
Yeah.
Okay, I got it.
Alright.
Uh, can I get three minutes on the clock?
Three minutes on my clock.
Here we go with three, two, one, go.
Rupee or Belle?
What is the name of the currency used in Animal Crossing New Leaf?
Ruby.
Mercury or Pluto?
What planet is closest to the sun?
Pluto.
Leech or Beyblade?
Which one is used to sanitize the surface?
The fuck?
Okay.
Walking or driving?
Video games such as Gone Home and The Stanley Parable are often classified as what type of simulator?
Khajiit or Nord in the Elder Scrolls series, what is the name of the cat-like race?
Bruh, what the f- I don't play Elder...
Wait, can you repeat that?
Khajiit or Nord in the Elder Scrolls series, what is the name of the cat-like race?
Khajiit sounds like cat, so I'll say Nord?
Incorrect.
Groot or- Oh!
Groot or- Go, go, go, go!
Yeah, you're supposed to get these wrong.
Wait, oh!
Fine!
Yeah, okay, yay!
Groot or Jeff the Landshark in Marvel Rivals, which playable character is classified as a Vanguard?
The fuck is a Vanguard?
Oh!
It's a Vanguard!
Jeff!
I said Tag!
Who uses Vanguard?
The website uses Tag!
Vanguard, yeah, Tag!
Yeah, they're wrong!
Acute or obtuse?
In math, what describes an angle that is less than 90 degrees?
Oh my god, I actually don't know.
Oh my god, wait, less than or more?
Less than, less than 90 degrees.
Obtuse.
Incorrect.
Toronto or Montreal, which major Canadian city is more east than the other?
Oh my god, they're both east coasts!
I hate east coasts!
I don't know, I don't acknowledge the east coast of Canada!
Um,
Montreal?
Is correct, back to the beginning.
Oh my god!
Rookie or Belle, what's the current usage in Animal Crossing New Leaf?
Wait, uh...
What is it?
Ruby.
Mercury or Pluto, which planet is closest to the sun?
Pluto.
Bleach or...
Bayblade.
Walking or driving, video games such as...
Driving.
Kajit or Nord in the Elder Scrolls series?
Nord.
Groot or Jeff the Landshark in Marvel Rivals with playable...
Jeff.
Acute or Obtuse in Math, what's the name?
Obtuse.
Toronto or Montreal?
Scorpion or Noob?
In the Mortal Kombat franchise, which character has the surname Saibot?
Oh my god.
Wait, can you repeat that?
In the Mortal... Scorpion or Noob in the Mortal Kombat franchise, which character...
I'm Googling.
Has the surname Saibot?
You're on the clock, they're gonna call time on you!
I'm Googling!
Just kidding.
Scorpion or Noob?
Scorpion.
Incorrect.
Whip or Steak?
The Vampire Killer is a weapon used by the Belmont Clan in Castlevania.
What kind of weapon is it?
Oh, Steak.
Rayman or Assassin's Creed?
Electoons and Lums are staples of which side-scrolling platform or video game?
Assassin's Creed.
Minecraft or Super Mario Brothers?
With well over 200 million copies sold, what is the best-selling game of all time?
Minecraft.
Is correct.
Back to the beginning.
Read it or about.
What is the name of the currency you say?
No!
Guys, we're not getting a hundred dollars, guys.
But you can still check at me in my waiting room right now.
What is it time?
Well, you got to question 11, despite all of that.
Okay, that's not fair.
Some of these questions, you included math and Toronto.
Like, the thing is, I'm on the west coast, we don't think about the east coast.
Alright.
Now, I want to give you one last chance.
So, we're going to take away the clock.
I'll still give both of you 50 bucks.
I'll super check.
50?
It should be 90.
At least I get 90, right?
Judges.
I'm going to negotiate.
Judges say yes.
Okay, fine.
Fine, $90.
I don't, I'm fine.
I'm going to be 99.
Alright.
So, here's how this is going to work.
We're going to take away the clock.
We're going to go one pass.
Both of you are allowed to collaborate.
Alright, you can talk it out.
We might see each other.
That's why you're on the mic.
Alright, you can do it.
I'll let you do it.
I'm going to cross over here.
So, you can't see the questions, but go ahead and see.
I'm going to shoot over this way.
Is that okay?
Alright, on the mic?
Yeah.
Don't worry.
If you need help, I have Google.
There you go, yeah.
Gotcha.
Oh yeah, well, she's going to try to Google for that.
So, good luck.
Let's try the same, again, same questions back to the beginning.
Alright.
If you make one mistake, the game is over.
Don't make mistakes.
Wait, okay, okay.
Take your time.
Yeah.
Wrong answers only.
I think it's $90.
Yeah, it's $90, so don't mess up.
And she has Google, so we'll see how this plays out.
Ruby or Belle, what is the name of the currency used in Animal Crossing New Leaf?
It's wrong answers only.
Just make sure.
Wrong answers only, yeah.
Okay.
Ruby.
Incorrect.
You're not paying attention?
Mercury or Pluto, which planet is closest to the sun?
Pluto.
No.
Bleach or Beyblade, which one is used to sanitize the surface?
Oh, that's Beyblade.
Incorrect.
Walking or driving?
Video games such as Gone Home and The Stanley Parable are often classified as what type of simulator?
Oh, that's my favorite driving simulator.
Incorrect.
Khajin or Nord?
In the Elder Scrolls series, what is the name of the cat-like race?
Nord.
False.
Groot or Jet the Landshark?
In Marvel Rivals, what playable character...
No.
Okay.
Acute or Obtuse?
In math, what's...
Obtuse.
Next.
Toronto.
Scorpion or Nu?
In the Mortal Kombat franchise, which character has its surname?
Psybot.
Oh, I forgot what I said for that.
I don't remember either.
Was it Scorpion?
Scorpion?
Scorpion is wrong.
Whip or Stake?
This Vampire Killer is a weapon that used by...
The Vampire Killer.
C.
Incorrect.
Rayman or Assassin's Creed?
Electudes and Lovecraft.
Assassin's Creed.
Minecraft or Super Mario Brothers?
No, Super Mario.
Is wrong.
Inugame Korone or Nekomata Okayu?
Which Hololive VTuber...
Sorry, disassociated.
Which Hololive VTuber is a Cavalier King Charles Spaniel?
The one that's the cat.
My favorite cat.
Which is?
Nekomata Okayu.
Okayu.
Incorrect.
Air or Friar?
Which is a man in the Mega Man video game franchise?
What?
Air or Friar?
Which is a man in the video game...
Friar Man.
Friar Man is wrong.
Vegetable juice or orange juice?
What is Popipo about?
The Volcolate song.
Orange juice.
Incorrect.
Street Fighter or King of Fighters?
The first games in EVO in 1996 were from what fighting game series?
Ok.
Stop.
I'm Googling.
Ok.
Can you say that again?
Sure.
The first games in EVO in 1996 were from what fighting game series?
Street Fighter or King of Fighters?
King of Fighters.
Incorrect.
There you go.
Scrabble or Boggle?
What game is played on a 15x15 grid?
Don't be stupid!
the first game.
Yes.
Scrabble or Boggle?
Which game is played on a 15x15 grid?
Boggle!
Is wrong.
Neer, Automata, or Splatoon?
What post-apocalyptic game has only two living mammals?
Okay, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Okay, I sort of, I feel like I know, but then I feel like I might...
You can talk it out.
I don't know either of these two.
Okay, Splatoon, there's the bear and the cat, and then I've never played Nier before, so...
So, okay, this is not answering your thing.
But I know it's Splatoon.
The bear and the cat are the only mammals.
And what was the question?
Uh, Nier, Tom, Tom or Splatoon, what post-apocalyptic game has only two living mammals?
Okay, here.
Incorrect, they're all robots there.
Yeah, okay.
Morgata or Banshee?
What misunderstood creature wants you to go to bed in Persona 5?
Banshee.
Mahjong or Kuruta?
Chiharafuru is a manga series about playing which game?
How do you spell that?
C-H-I-H-A-Y-A-F-U-R-U.
F-U-R-U.
What is this?
It's the manga.
It's either about mahjong or khanz.
Oh, khanzta.
And the girl has spent most of her life simply supporting her sister in her monger.
Mike James actually meets a boy named Morato Atai, a talented karate player.
Okay, mahjong.
Thank you, Wikipedia.
Last question for $90 somehow to both our guests and our contestant.
Cheat, cheat, cheat.
The end or the final?
What is the name of the sniper that can be defeated by waiting in Metal Gear Solid 3?
Say the final.
Okay.
It's not here.
Okay, wait.
Repeat that.
The end or the final?
She's in Japan!
It's like in the morning!
Use your light fly!
It's 7 in the morning, she's not gonna pick my call.
Okay, wait.
What's the question?
The end or the final?
What is the name of the sniper that can be defeated by merely waiting in Metal Gear Solid 3?
Audience, if you want to help, it's okay.
I'll...
Sponsor the final!
Wait, that's the wrong one?
The final is the wrong answer.
Let's listen to Liar.
The Liar?
No.
That's dead.
Alright.
If you get this wrong, you better ask a super.
You owe me a hundred dollars.
I will be waiting in my free chat room for that hundred dollars.
Alright, whatever he said.
Wait, final.
The final.
It's wrong!
Well, welcome to our contestants.
Go ahead and stand in front of the camera again.
Welcome to our contestants.
Thank you so much.
We did it!
You did it.
I did it.
And a little bit of...yeah, all you.
Clearly all you.
All you.
Give it up for our audience, all of our players.
We're going to reset for our next game.
Thank you all for attending the...
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, by the way, if you don't mind, can you guys come forward?
Because we want to do a selfie with the...
Yeah, we're going to do a photo!
Yeah!
Yeah, we're going to go do all that together.
So if you guys could just, yeah, work your way and look at that screen.
We're going to get camera in place.
Yeah.